[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Connor to Bryan here and you are
listening to episode 2 the Lost Hans and
Franz movie discussing a script that was
written in 1991 by Dana Carvey Kevin
Newman Robert Smigel and myself it was
our Dream to bring Hans and Franz to the
big screen as a musical we wrote the
script and here we are after all these
years bringing it to life
we all know this is going to lead to the
movie actually being made
uh and um so I'm clearing my schedule
for the summer for a budget of one
hundred thousand dollars
it'll be on streaming you'll see it's
gonna be great you know in the last
episode we talked a little bit about how
Hans and Franz came to be and I think
this is important before we start this
reading the next uh parts of the script
Kevin it all began with you seeing
Arnold Schwarzenegger doing an interview
and you were kind of enjoyed doing his
voice you called Dana the two of you
you're out on the road together with
Dennis Miller hey cha cha and you were
uh
looks like currency once he gave me a
pluggy wonky
um you two were on the road together uh
and you started doing these two guys but
you were still you didn't quite see how
it could be a character yet and then
Dana you said there was a point where
there was an important yeah revelation
we played with it we had the core I
think that they would maybe be the
cousins and maybe of Schwarzenegger of
Arnold and worship Arnold we had that
distant cousins but we were trying to
think of the characters like what would
they be and we were going around with
like are they actually going to lift
weights like are they going to show that
they're strong wrong and we were
probably thought not but what would they
do so I'm talking with Kevin and first
we were just on the phone doing we went
to Palm you up we thought okay let's do
that and then Kevin we were just riffing
around like this and that and then Kevin
said I'll never forget it because it
really it tilted the whole thing and if
you don't believe it was properly pumped
up once we got defensive then we laughed
for two hours on the phone if you doubt
me in any way you know and they would
never lift weights so I think in the
first the first they never demonstrated
their strength of the audience all they
did the paranoid delusional sadistic
aggressive of toward imaginary enemies
and that was their whole thing that's
why I don't think the first one or two
really scored the first one is
unbelievably funny if you watch it now
but did the audience got hooked it
harder as it went along to yeah of
course yeah well what happens almost
every character yeah right the first
wins world wasn't well a giant hit I
guess it was just how abstract it was
showing like we did the first one we we
set it up and they got it okay it was
the last sketch of the show yeah and
then uh we didn't do it for a couple
weeks I said Dana we should do another
one of those and see if uh and then we
put it out there and it was like you
know it was like yeah people loved it
yeah you know eventually we had the
whole crowd going we want to pop and
then the whole eight Acres
I think more so more so back back that
era of SNL everybody was always on the
hunt for a catchphrase and I remembered
very clearly and there was some you know
pump you up I could see you guys
thinking what's the catchphrase going to
be right yeah everything everything gets
wound down into we want to pump you up
to we want to Farmville we had to stop
because I was gonna chef with the
reduction you keep cooking it until it
just becomes this it's like the bush
thing not gonna do it not got that yeah
well we've watched you do uh the whole
Arc of George of George Bush was you
starting out saying not gonna do it and
then over time again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's had a horrible stroke yeah it went
like this not God dad got that go
combining two catchphrases instead of
living
so uh we're gonna get back into it now
uh as you last remember Hans and Franz
they lose their job at their cable
television show because they refer to Dr
Martin Luther King as being flabby
um they're fired they ride out on tandem
bikes and they get to Hollywood they're
hoping to meet their their cousin Arnold
so we take you now let's get Arnold in
here let's get Arnold in here yeah let's
get him in here let's get to work this
is here we go let's do this
reduced to eating letters of the
Hollywood sign for sustenance
[Laughter]
have no luck finding their cousin in Los
Angeles until they are arrested for
tackling Arnold at one of his movie
premieres Arnold bails them out of jail
and allows him to crash at his house
meanwhile Rolf continues to kidnap girly
men exterior Arnold's house day a huge
sprawling estate Arnold Humvees drive
past two large flexed metal arms which
serve as the gate and chair Arnold's
foyer moments later a very pumped man's
servant takes everyone's bag as they
enter thanks Benny make yourselves
comfortable fellas the house is
decorated with large sculptures of
individual muscles wow what a great
place yeah it's cool for now as they
follow Arnold into the living room they
cross a staircase made up of 15
connected stairmasters ascending to the
next level
the living room furniture is also shaped
like different muscles these rooms where
I like to unwind
before we forget we got some stuff for
you from back home they pull some junk
out of a knapsack we brought you your
mail Hans hands Arnold some old junk
mail uh yeah thanks and also he posted
beat up dirty sausage out of his
knapsack your favorite sausage with
Grandma my cook for you
Ah that's nice uh thanks thanks guys
Arnold reaches over and opens a cabinet
a digital monitor reads out 14 calories
burned Arnold pulls out a cigar and
lights it let me show you the rest of
the place Arnold gets up Hans and Franz
Trail himself sure sure I'd love to
Arnold can I use the bathroom please
sure go down to the bicep make a left at
the Baltic
thanks Hans continues to follow Arnold
here come with me Arnold's backyard
moments later they cross the swimming
pool a narrow lap pool that stretches a
mile into the Horizon there is a yacht
in the deep end
nice
they continue to follow Arnold elsewhere
he leads them through a secret
passageway a giant
a giant buttocks that separates and
opens like a door
Arnold's basement moments later it is a
complex underground nerve center not
unlike the war room and Dr Strangelove
is what all happens fellas I make every
Korea move in this room a team of
advisors is starting a giant tabletop
chart pushing around a small cardboard
cutout heads of Sylvester Stallone Chuck
Norris Jean-Claude Van Damme Kevin
Costner Etc Hans and Franz are very
impressed show business is like a war
you must always anticipate the enemies
next move Arnold turns to Howard an
agent in an Italian suit how's it
looking for The Pride of the Yankees
remake Costner met with them today blow
him out
I was meant to play Lou Gehrig come come
Arnold church and leads Hansen France to
another Wing where scientists and lab
coats are studying x-rays muscles and
skeletal charts who are these people are
not Muslim research you can't forget
pompitude it's my bread and butter a
scientist approaches Arnold any new
exercises called me you know this little
bump on the inside of your elbow it's
technically a ligament but we think it
can be made thicker with inverted curls
come over here fellas they walk over to
a machine that resembles a Sleek version
of an old steam box this machine removes
all hair from your body so you're ready
for competition a hairy Italian
bodybuilder and Speedo trunk steps into
the machine which makes whirling and
buzzing sounds thanks Franco I want to
give something back to the bodybuilding
Community the machine stops the Italian
bodybuilder steps out hairless from the
neck down he checks under his speed and
gives a thumbs up Arnold moves on to a
private Alcove here's my real Trident
Joy he presses a button on the wall a
sliding door opens revealing a gleaming
rectangular metal box for years man has
been poisoning his body with his unsafe
chemicals in his mad quest for bulk
soon the madness will end with my new
totally safe
anabolic bulk enhancer wow a man will
finally realize his dream to go from
this he refers to a photo of an enormous
bodybuilder with bulging muscles
he refers to a photo of the same
bodybuilder doctor to look three times
as muscular it's a truly disgusting
sight
oh my God
it comes as a cracker
Arnold opens classic Conan joke I love
that it comes Arnold opens the metal box
revealing rows of round crackers Franz
reaches for one Arnold slaps his wrist
the crackles haven't been protected now
let's go and remember don't tell anyone
they leave the Alcove and are
intercepted by Howard Arnold I know you
have guests but right fellas uh this is
my agent Howard hello girlie man nice to
meet you Friday person Howard gives
songs and Friends a look they smile
oblivious
I remember uh we would get so excited
about uh jokes where it was very flat
him talking about all that that wondrous
thing and then saying something like
it's a cracker well that was totally
your joke but but but just the just the
idea that then Arnold has to say cracker
the great Arnold word hearing the real
Arnold do this would have been just
incredible yeah we would have done
anything just to have the table exactly
is going to be when we remake it so
funny in this movie because the visual
get through the house that whole thing
is placed so there was a whole scene
remember the scene where Arnold's on the
phone and he's doing like he's
multitasking he's doing like 20 things
at once yeah controlling because he was
such an enormous star yeah at this time
that we were able to just exaggerate not
only his Fame but also his just like he
was like a superhero within the movie
yeah we had lunch with him at uh
yeah and to talk about this movie yeah
had one meeting with him and I'll just
set the table which is down in Venice
there was a restaurant called schatzis
that I think Arnold owned yeah he bought
it for his mother yeah and it was um you
could get like Austrian food there and
you know just as a side note I think who
used to sometimes frequent that little
area it was sort of an outdoor kind of
mini mall area and schatzi's was there
and um I later heard from Rick Ludwin
that Johnny Carson used to go there and
he would meet Johnny Carson at that same
place
yeah
but you know what this is what I heard
from Rick Gladwin a good friend of of
ours going back years on SNL and the
Late Night show he said that he was
having one of his meetings with Johnny
Carson who was retired but like still
just just this huge legendary figure
yeah and he's sitting there at shots
he's with Rick Loveland they're having a
lunch and um Arnold came by and it was a
whole thing like we miss you Johnny you
know it was all about you've got to come
back on television and Johnny
oh thank you very much but I have a good
time on my boat
he's having a good time on his boom well
I know how did you get here
what are you bothering Johnny
what to do what are you doing leave them
alone where did he come out of the heat
vent he was listening in
man put him everywhere yeah yeah I was
just in the kitchen yeah
I went to that place once I met him
there once without you guys and Arnold
yeah and at the end he's like okay time
for cigars and Schnapps and he had a
cigar cutter and then you had to do a
shot of schnapps
at the end of a meal it's like a
exclamation time so we should talk about
this because we did have a meeting with
Schwarzenegger yes we all went and I
remember there was some other people
there too obviously some agents and
normally you'd have Australian friends
around like big
guys yeah in this case it was just uh
agents and things yeah and I didn't
remember having any interaction with
them other than hi fellas I mean I think
he talked to you you're not at a table
Yeah we sat at a table but I'm saying do
you remember I remember him talking
about the first thing he said first
thing he said you guys have gone crazy
with the Pyrex giant buttocks opening
and closing I remember he went so he had
read it he had read it or at least
enough of it but he mentioned that one
he was excited at that point then he was
just telling us about his other projects
and yeah I'm gonna be uh I play a
pregnant guy and it's really touching
and heartwarming you know because I go
through and I understand what the women
go through and the comedies because the
man you know traditionally doesn't have
a value from being pregnant
I like that he gets into it because a
man doesn't have a uterus you see yeah
he does not have all these things you
know the thing that you use to urinate
yeah that's what the women don't have
that men only
let me write out a diagram that was
weird let me tell you something I'm the
only man who's pregnant that has a
six-pack over the belly of the little
child even the child has a six packs
inside it's my six-pack would crush the
child but we hear any chance Arnold like
three months from now is driving down
the road listening to this sure yeah
yeah it's funny you know maybe we go
back really visited my dream would just
be for him to do a live reading with us
and just do it for charity that would be
or for us or for us just for money
we say it's for charity and then we
pocket the money yeah yeah I've done
that many times and people people rarely
look into it they don't know there's no
forensic audit that's
a lie happy Martin had a great joke
Steve Martin did a charity he goes
congratulations you've raised 500 000
minus my salary
so that's 200 for the kids
all right we're gonna go back to it now
and uh here we go
interior Arnold's house kitchen
uh what are you fellas cooking
yeah we figured it was our last night
France Pierce is a piece with a fork
continually offers it to Arnold Arnold
Isaac cautiously then tasted my God is
just how I tasted in the old country
Arnold how come you never talk about the
old country it's not the most Pleasant
memory believe me now let it out I was a
happy child but it wasn't easy for my
family to serve to exterior the old
country Marketplace 30 years ago
poverty-stricken villagers exchange
sparse items some children are lifting
tiny weights
it was during the war food and weights
were hard to come by
families struggle to stay pumped
[Laughter]
dissolved to Water's Edge later young
Arnold age 15 with flowing locks in
lederhosen hugging his family I loved my
simple life but I was too massive for my
family to support So in desperation
exterior ocean later young Arnold
floating in a giant bottle across the
ocean
they sent me to the states the only way
they could afford to promising they join
me later exterior our silent day young
Arnold online with tons of other
immigrants still I felt abandoned and
then on Ellis Island I was humiliated
young Arnold steps up to the immigration
Booth they shortened my name a rude
clerk is in the booth what's your name
son
Arnold Schwarzenegger slots and Klausen
okay forget it now you're Schwarzenegger
young Arnold is stunned he walks away
slowly then stops I had nothing left so
I told myself I'd never look back just
off to ensure Arnold's office day in
1979 Pan the wall posters of Arnold as
Mr Olympia Arnold in Pumping Iron Arnold
as Conan the Barbarian Etc I focused on
my career and it paid off a 70s Arnold
receives a phone call then one day I got
a call from Little Austria my grandpa
was sick I thought I'd finally make
amends exterior little Austria Church
Day morning villagers were gathered
outside a casket emerges from the
entrance Arnold is the lone pallbearer
carrying the casket by one handle he is
downcast but I was too late he sadly
does a rep with the casket
exterior Arnold's pool same Hans and
Franz are taking it in we never knew or
not we never knew yeah yeah you can
never get it back fellas Arnold how
about a doozle schnapps you guys
[Music]
I don't know fellas exterior Arnold's
pool later all three are drunk giggling
hysterically and joking in German as
they laugh
yeah
I do it because I'm insecure
I love you guys
don't leave tomorrow okay Arnold starts
an Austrian Drinking Song in Hanson
France joining
you know
it's really fun to imagine the real
Schwarzenegger I know but at what point
do you want to talk about why the movie
didn't get me well one thing I'll start
the conversation with this is that I was
naive personally yeah and found out
later maybe from the late great Brad
Gray he's got like 10 things at all
times he has multiple multiple projects
yeah I was I didn't really realize how
you know we were not necessarily on the
top of the list but we might have got
made but I was probably thinking more
like maybe had two projects or three
yeah
I have like five projects lined up for
myself and I want to do is it depends on
you know what I'm looking for we're not
talking about yard work Kevin oh I see I
thought you were is this one of your
projects right now no no it's raking
leaves and shovels this doesn't count as
a project yeah I'm screwed but in
retrospect isn't it I mean there are
other reasons too but he always movie
stars huge movie stars like the rock
doesn't have like just two two things
but I remember a specific phone call
that like I got to talk to to his was
there a guy named Lou do you guys
anybody else
and the guy tells me that uh because so
while we were waiting Last Action Hero
came out and kind of bombed and Last
Action Hero he didn't play himself but
he played it was a tongue-in-cheek
as an action hero as an action hero and
uh Lou basically said that Arnold it was
almost like you know disproves the law
that you can't do yourself I'll never do
myself in the movie again right right
that was no Last Action that he took
from that at the time we heard that
because Last Action Hero came out I
don't know if it came out while we were
writing it I think he was developing
that then while he was talking to us
about this yes he was so it's that
it was an Andor if we got into it first
maybe would have got made then we would
have been you never to make fun of
yourself after 30 minutes before that or
if ours had been a hit then he would
have just you always make
there must be buttock stores in every
movie I make
really was he was the biggest like
muscular guy like now they got so many
action stars like that you know they got
rock no but skinny yeah skinny movie
stars get incredibly pumped up now yeah
like Jake click and holler just normal
clicking off his brother clickenheimer
yeah Jake love him great actors probably
listening but they all have to do
superhero that's a normal frame but then
it's like you know I will say this have
you seen Kumail I mean oh yeah but
totally but I will say this uh have you
seen me
if you're looking at the people that do
a lot of them I'm gonna that do the
action movies or the Marvel movies they
get uh very cut but Arnold was different
Arnold at his Peak was massive in a way
that none of these guys are I mean he
really was he's a legit bodybuilder yeah
he was a real bodybuilder so the rock
might be bigger than Arnold I think
physically physically at this point I
don't think so really but Arnold
but I I'd have to see him side by side
in their Prime I'm going to say the that
gold was a body pillow Arnold was a
bodybuilder though and and The Rock was
a wrestler I know I'm just I I just I'll
ask some gym rats about that but I think
he was also you could be more Reckless
about it then but uh here's something
everyone will find fascinating no I was
gonna do bad boys because this guy's
always talk about it even with me and
love it yes yeah so turned it down but
in the meantime Simpson and brookheimer
I was going to play the Will Smith part
you know and they said yeah we're gonna
get a trainer we're gonna add two inches
to your chest good God to try to build
me up to be like I mean Will Smith is
like six four it's crazy he's not six
four all right two and a half nope but
anyway they even tried to do it to me I
graduated high school at this height at
125. it would have been a heavy lift no
pun intended but you know what I love is
um the insane commitment to the
weightlifting thing which even when you
were describing them as being in this
really the thing that there wasn't much
food to eat and it was hard to get
weights a weight is anything you can
lift I love the stupidity
there wasn't much money for weights it
was like that
that being a hardship weights have to be
flown in to this impoverished area so
people can bump up
all right that does it for the second uh
episode of Hans and Franz The girlyman
Dilemma this is the table read we're
bringing this magical script from 1991
to life with uh Dana Carvey Kevin Neal
and Robert smigiel and myself so stick
around for the next episode where things
really heat up we never even had a table
read for the original no we didn't that
would have been fun wow couldn't afford
a table we've gotten could have punched
it up for that maybe if Arnold had just
come to a table read and heard the
laughs he would have yeah got a time
machine
foreign